and then on Tuesday his team went out and beat
the Islanders 3-2 their first and eight on the
road they were 06 and one a save there
by lions so they struggled on the road
won that one and one last night from Center
corac will rifle it in Lion will slow it down
for cider moved it along but Mark stone is
there one of the league leaders in takeaways
that shot being occupied in the building
when that was going on we don't see much
fighting anymore when it does happen boy
people loveing loving here's Pon up along
with pper and fabri and a save there by Logan
Thompson right shot left side with room and
the shot was blocked Vegas like Philadelphia
very good shot blocking team out one gets in
L on Logan Thompson and he made the save Vegas
third in the league in block shot Philadelphia
Fifth Head by patri here comes Raymond
with the brink it back to lurin he
scores Raymond Raymond's going for the PT it's
goal 200 for Dylan and the point streaks at 11
games all three of them the brecket oh over to
Raymond back the Larin who's ready to shoot and
he hits as a right-handed catching gender
Thompson ify another sellout crowd here
at Little Caesars that was Dylan's 200th of
his career 504 from De Bret and Raymond R mus
save by Logan Thompson lead pass Martinez
wasn't handled there by Stone back with it
is Walman crowd Lively early in this one
on later start at Little Caesars with the
Pistons this afternoon wman fires scars
what a bullet wman top shelf it's two to
nothing Redwing defensing with 10 or more goals
since Mike Green back in 1617 at 14 wow boy you
had lots of time to walk into this David pan with
the setup Vegas's week two Loop defensively and
now no Falls of the goal tender here this Puck
the flex off of Vegas player right it hit it up
when he had 14 in the 161 17 season back in here
for barbashev drops it off for Jonathan maraso
coming off his fifth regular season hattrick
last night at Madison Square Garden second this
season oh loose in front of the n they score they
bang it through the legs of Alex lion and it's
barbashev getting a stick on it big goal for
Vegas to come back after that wman goal that
quickly mad scrambled in front of the net bit
of a loose Puck actually and he just Dives and
chips it really this Puck is thrown to the
side of the net it is deflected first of all
and that makes it tough if not impossible for a
goenda the rebound and uh just a tiip cut for G
PA oh big hit as white cloud crunch
brass hou but came to the middle Ma
and a save there by Thompson and taken away by
Stone Lian plays it high and off the
glass didn't get out petrangelo able
to keep it in Cross for Martinez winds up
and scores what a bullet Rochester Hills
Alec Martinez got out over the
Blue Line petrangelo keeps it in
nicely and I believe this may have hit Comer
on its way to the net this replay will tell
you what does it hit anything well is this two
Michigan guys there it is right there yeah C it
might have been cotter's goal it is Potter from
Canton Martinez from Rochester Hills Potter's
first goal in his hometown in less than two to
go in the first 40 seconds remaining in the power
play to Brink it after his teeth were
rattled cider down low back and there
scar Bano great to two
Jo valeno get very little time on the power play
this Puck goes off the defender so it hasn't been
a good night for the goenda bad luck there is no
luck for him deleno off the stick and maybe the
skate into the slot it comes and Chandler
Stevenson the good Skating Center
into the high slot the shot and a save by line
and too good a chance there for Kaden cor too
good was a great a scoring chance for sure
and Detroit misses something defensively here
good thing that stone got out of the way at the
time that he did and Alex cion solid as you know
what a rock back here is trying to do something
special now left it there for Larkin who's been
special and off the outside of the post Dylan
with the first goal of this game f for what a
no it did not what a save that was well Dylan
Lin again trying short side he cranked it off
the short side goal PS up high he scored lots
of goals from there and there what a setup and
Raymond Dynamite scoring chance and that's a big
time save by Thompson to keep it a one PAB gains
Center and shoots it in offside though but then
they tag up so the play continues loose here for
pon pon right to the goal and a save rebound and
just sent by by faab back to get it is ma 4 35 to
go in the second long stretch pass for confer in
for pan pan right in across and a big stop there
on fabric flying down the ice about 25 mph and
if that puck hadn't been in fabry's feet he might
have made it 4-2 as uh pan was being checked he
couldn't make make the perfect pass P triangelo
kept it alive now it stolen WR he's exhausted does
he have enough in the tank in on goal big stop by
Thompson here's a
look rmle now with his fifth NHL
team playing just his 16th NHL
game Potter here we go back pass and a save made
off Mario that's a huge save as as right there
and a big time save by the Lions Locker
save off the high glass by lion back to
Martinez blocked by cop laid in space there
for rash mus along with CP C's got it fire
scar for Andrew cop goals in consecutive
games this line started the third
period Ken they had only 12 shifts
in the game before the puck drop
for the start of the third and
they were on the ice usually Lon
uses them a lot Maro Martinez to
petangel block in down another block clear ahead
Lin for the empty net scor WoW block shot made all
this happen he's not on the score sheet for goals
and assists maybe Kane comes back Wednesday if not
just after the break and shat getting healthy
and the Red Wings win it by a final score of
5-2